كيف تشكلت هذه القناعه بانه لاحل لجيوب
المقاومه في غزه عند المستوى العسكري
الاسرائيلي
اليوم
اي دائما حسن عندما تذهب القوى العسكريه
الى الارض لديها خطه واستراتيجيه معينه
تضع اهداف عسكريه لتحقيق الاهداف السياسيه
ولكن دائما الميدان يعكس شيء لم يكن
بالحسبان اذا لم يكن هناك القدره على
التاقلم وحتى اذا تم الاصطدام عسكريا
تغيير الاهداف السياسيه هذا الامر يصل الى
حائط مسدود اليوم اسرائيل تستعمل اقصى
قدراتها العسكريه والجيش الاسرائيلي يصنف
بالعالم حسب مجله الفوربس ال 14 في العالم
14 تكنولوجيا وعسكريا ونوعيا يصطدم اليوم
بمقاتلي اطار الدوله حضر نفسه وبالتالي
نتجت ه هذه الخسائر المهمه من هنا قد يمكن
القول انه هذا صعب تحقيق الاهداف التي
وضعتها القياده السياسيه طيب هذا ماذا
سيغير في الواقع الميداني بالنسبه لما
يقوم به جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في غزه
يعني عندما يقتنع بان هذا الهدف لن يتحقق
بالتالي ما هي الاهداف الاخرى التي يذهب
اليها في عملياته
العسكريه
ايه حسن دائما الاهداف العسكريه لم
تتحقق هناك ثمن كبير العوده دائما الى
الحل السياسي يعني صمود المقاومه حاليا هو
لانزال الكثير من الخسائر في الجيش
الاسرائيلي لتغيير القرار السياسي اليوم
يسعى الاسرائيلي الى خطه معينه وهذا حسب
المؤشرات على الارض الانتقال الى المرحله
الثالثه يعتبرها انتهت في شمال غزه وانتقل
الى معركه منخفضه الحده ولكن باستمرار
المقاومه في الوسط يريد التشابه مع الشمال
وحتى في خان يونس لتصبح كل غزه منقسمه الى
ثلاثه اقسام منخفضه الحده والمرحله
الثالثه والسعي دائما الى ضرب عنصرين
مهمين هما الانفاق والصواريخ التي تضرب
الداخل الاسرائيلي وهنا تكمن المعضله
الكبرى ولكن هناك معضله اخرى ربما لدى
الجيش الاسرائيلي وهو ق المقاومه
باستهدافه من خلف
الخطوط بالطبع وهنا يعني عندما قلت ان ان
الانفاق هي الجزء الاساسي الانفاق حسن
تعطي انسيابيه وليونه وقدره على المناوره
للمقاومه وتمتد على كامل القطاع 700 م حسب
النيويورك تايمز وهذا الامر يعطي القدره
للمقاومه على حتى ولو حصرت في مكان ما هي
قادره على الخروج من من خلف خطوط العدو
وهذا ما لاحظناه في بيت حنون في بيت لهيه
في جحر الديك وفي مناطق كثيره داخل القطاع
طيب ماذا لو يعني اتخذ الجيش الاسرائيلي
هذا المسار الذي اشرت اليه ولكنه في
المقابل سيبقى عرضه لعمليات المقاومه
والاستهداف كما نشاهد بشكل
يومي سيدفع الثمن مع الوقت ولكن هو يريد
الانتقال الى ما يسمى بالرو او الروتين
يعني لا يكون هناك قدره على للمقاومه على
قصف الداخل الاسرائيلي هو يعيد مستوطنات
غلاف غزه وبالتالي يتم التعامل بالمعنى
السياسي حتى ولو كانت منخفضه الحده هذا هو
الهدف البعيد المدى حتى ولو كان هناك
خسائر وهذا مؤشر مهم رايناه في شمال غزه
يعني هو انسحب ارتاحت المقاومه بدات
عمليات معينه محدوده وعند كل حد معين
واستعلام معين واستخبارات معينه يرسل ما
يسمى بالتاسار يعني قوه مكونه للتعامل مع
هذا الهدف حتى ولو كان هناك خسائر كبيره
ولكنه لن يستطيع السيطره على اي منطقه
يكون فيها داخل القطاع